Late last night, Twitter's
owner and chief
twit Elon Musk said
that Trump, who has been banned since
inciting an insurrection
at the Capitol
on January 6th,
is now back on the platform.
Let us discuss all of this
and more with CNN's Nia-Malika Henderson.
Jonathan Swan of Axios,
Margaret Talev of Axios, and CNN's
Manu Raju.
It feels like deja vu a little bit.
The combination of Trump
going out there and talking witch hunts,
but also he's back on Twitter
What will that mean
for him, for our politics
this time around?
Is he back on Twitter, his Twitter?
Remember, like three days?
Joe is like three days ago.
It was like, this is my last tweet.
If I knew that was my last tweet,
I would have done whatever.
Like, I I don't know what this is.
I don't know what Twitter is.
I don't know what Elon Musk is doing.
And most Americans don't read Twitter.
Margaret, Margaret is all of us.
We don't know what is going on.
But I mean, the reality is that,
you know, just listen to Trump.
This is what he said last night
about whether or not
he would even be interested in
coming back to Twitter,
to social
is is through the roof.
It's doing phenomenally well.
Truth social
has been very, very powerful,
very, very strong.
And I'll be saying that.
But I hear we're getting a big vote
to also go back on Twitter.
I don't see it
because I don't see any reason for it.
Truth, social media,
if you're wondering, is the other thing
Americans don't know anything about,
and I think that's
the crux of the matter.
Can he resist this bigger?
It's a much bigger audience.
On Twitter
than he ever got on Twitter social.
So no matter what he says here,
there will always be a temptation
for Trump to take the bigger megaphone.
Yeah, I've spoken to a few of his aides
over the last
several months about this question,
because when it became clear
that Elon Musk
was probably going to buy Twitter,
then the next question was, okay,
does Trump get back on?
He's saying publicly he won't do it.
But pretty much everyone
I talked to thinks that at some point
he's going to go back on this.
If he if he judges that it's expedient
and useful to him,
which he believes it is,
he thinks it's his voice
directly to the people, etc., etc..
Now,
it's kind of the worst nightmare
of the Republican leadership on the Hill.
Because, you
know, and
members of Congress
and they have to deal with people
like Manu
running up to them saying,
have you seen Trump's latest tweet?
And they say, no,
I don't know what you're talking about.
And they run off down the hall.
So, you know, I don't know.
I don't have any reporting
that he is going to go back on.
But most people around him
suspect that that is absolutely right.
That is a concern with social.
Republicans could say
they didn't see it because it is.
And everyone believes that
most people did not see it
because those people did. Yes.
I mean,
but when he tweets, it is right
in the middle of what people are seeing
when people are consuming
what the media is consuming.
And then that
forces Republicans to respond,
which is what has been
was such a headache
during the Trump presidency.
So if we respond,
if he does get involved in this,
I'm sure he won't have many.
There won't be many people
on Capitol Hill who are happy about this.
Yeah.
I mean, it's been
it has been such a boon
to Republicans
that they have not had to deal with this
on a regular basis.
And I think that we are actually
entering this
perfect storm
for a lot of sort of the establishment.
We have a drawn out
Georgia runoff in a few weeks.
Trump is declared. He's running again.
He's maybe going to be back on Twitter
I feel
like I'm
hearing a lot more nervousness
about what this could mean
in amping up the frustration
of the American people
with the kinds of stuff
that they have twice now.
But yeah,
Republicans quite worried
about this particular in this Georgia
runoff race is December 6th.
Does Trump insert himself there?
Because now
he's obviously run for president
and people are covering him much more.
Does he get back on Twitter?
It is a different landscape,
though, right?
It's even a different media landscape.
I think one of the big questions
we all have is
how is if
he tweets in the way that he used to?
Does the media sort of do wall
to wall outrage coverage
in the way that a lot of us did in
in the past at this point?
Can he
I mean, what could he tweet
that could cause outrage at this point?
Right.
I mean, he fomented an insurrection.
He's been racist.
He's been sexist.
He's been terrible in so many ways.
And it was kind of part
of the culture there
that there would be this outrage.
We'll see who he is on Twitter
and we'll see what the reception is,
not only from the media,
but but you see the media
saying we're not going to do this again,
but starting to do it again.
And you also see Republicans
saying it's time to move on.
But if you have 16
Republicans in a GOP primary, guess what?
We're going to be right back and start.
Speaking of deja vu, here we are again.
We have another special counsel
in all of these Trump cases.
He is facing so many investigations
to DOJ, once classified documents,
January six.
But then there is also
the January 6th select committee,
which is on its way out the door,
the Georgia investigation,
which a lot of people say
might be his biggest problem.
The House Ways and Means tax probe.
The Manhattan D.A.
is on his case, and the New York A.G.
is also
investigating his companies for fraud.
There's a lot going on that is
looming on the horizon for Trump.
Will it matter?
I mean, if he
gets indicted,
surely it's hard to game out.
And you know,
especially in
this Republican primary electorate,
you don't want to make sweeping
predictions about what
an indictment might do to
Donald Trump's
approval rating among public
and private voters.
There's probably a few, though,
who won't love it.
Probably a few voters who think
probably not. Great. Just just a few.
Yeah.
So Donald
Trump sees
the special counsel
through the lens of his
personal experience
with the special counsel,
which was with Robert Mueller,
which he saw as this unending witch hunt.
So while most people expected this
to happen, Trump
views it through that lens.
He's been told by his advisers
that being a
presidential candidate
does not immunize him from indictment.
But I've been told by people close to him
that he still sees it
as politically advantageous
sorry, legally
advantageous to be alive
political candidate
in this context.
He's following the same playbook
as he did with Mueller saying, you know,
this is a witch ongoing
and left wing prosecutor
or even like this.
Jackson was a career prosecutor
at the Justice Department.
But the difference between Mueller
and now remember,
he was a president then.
The reason
why Mueller did not come to a conclusion
and say there was
he should be prosecuted
on the issue of obstruction
to the Mueller report
because he was bound by Justice
Department policy
saying you can't charge
a sitting president.
He is not a prisoner anymore.
He could most certainly be charged.
So this is a much different circumstance
for Trump.
He's got a lot of legal exposure.
I mean, he has said
that he won't partake in it.
I don't know that he has a choice
in terms of partaking in it,
but he'll certainly use
this same strategy.
You know,
I mean, he has taken on so much water
over these last two weeks,
not only with the sound defeat
of election
deniers, his candidates
in the midterm election,
but with this news, he will say,
oh, this is good for him.
And it'll certainly,
I think, by net 30% or
so of the Republican Party to him.
But again,
this is not good for his chance.
Overall, I think the only thing that
the only argument
in any way
that this could be good for him
is that special
prosecutors often
take a long time
or get bogged down in things.
But this is someone who's much
whose experience includes war crosses.
Jack, Jack Smith.
Jack Smith, you disappointed
International Criminal
Court at The Hague
War Crimes Investigations
and prosecutions
and public corruption
cases back in the U.S., including
against police officers gone rogue.
So this is someone who
is not going to be politically
bound up in any of this
or worrying about it
and has a tremendous amount of
broad experience
and understands the imperative
to move swiftly.
And, of course,
I mean, the American people
play a role in all of this.
Again,
Trump lost the last time around in part
because people
are kind of sick of the chaos
and it feels like
we are about to be
in a brew
of more chaos
for at least the next two years.
And of course, the question is
will Republican primary voters
agree with that
or are they tired of the chaos?
Do they want to move on?
That's going to be the first question.
It will also be interesting to see
whether Trump's allies on the Hill
echo his claims of being a victim of
the witch hunt here.
Do they go after the special constantly?
So some of that from the House
Judiciary Committee.
Republicans are attacking him on Friday.
A lot of them were saying
there should be a special counsel.
The Hunter Biden investigation
that's happening right now
in the Justice Department.
So are seeing some of that.
But will they go along with his playbook
and demonizing the special counsel?
Oh, they keep an open mind
because this is a serious investigation.